the jurogan experience
you think that this is a process
that is leading towards what
do you extrapolate do you do you really
think that like do you wonder like what
humans are actually doing what
consciousness is actually doing why the
universe has this as a a tendency or a
law yeah no it's i think it's the most
mysterious question there is um so is
there an ultimate goal right uh so
uh what i do think is that
uh this increase in complexity is
inevitable but like i said it's not this
straight march of progress there's like
constantly these challenges there's
massive existential challenges and that
is the only thing
that pushes us
uh to create solutions so there's this
principle in the book that i call
poppers principle named after uh
philosopher of science karl popper
and uh the idea is that um
yes so that that our challenges
uh are what force us to find solutions
so if progress is going to always
continue that means the challenges won't
stop
so even if we do attain some like
globally unified state i would like to
see like some sort of
agreement
among nations that says okay we're all
going to demilitarize and we're going to
put this money into like medicine or
technology whatever
else you know all the other things that
you know we could be funding that could
help you know human society
uh
and you know
we could
have something like that but there were
there could still be like pandemics
there could still be someone crazy that
takes over and starts to
you know try to reverse that
so the point is you can never reach a
utopia
and even if we did it wouldn't be a
utopia for a long time because
the world is always changing it's this
you know reality is this noisy thermally
fluctuating thing and there is chaos
chaoses
uh needed for complexity too
um
actually when a system transitions to a
state of higher order
uh you need some chaos in the system
so that's because like if a system is
too rigid and too um
so you could think of like
things seemed we had democratic
presidents like you could
think about um
just like how things were under obama
for a while you know we didn't
there wasn't the craziness that we're
seeing today so you might think like oh
well whatever that system was it was a
good thing or it was better than what we
have now but no system no model no way
of doing things will work forever
because
uh
the external world is always changing so
we're always going to be going through
these
cycles and phases where we have uh
temporary stability but then the system
needs to change and i think right now
when we're seeing all this chaos
it is indicative of what uh complexity
scientists call a phase transition
and so basically uh the chaos
uh is basically the system screaming for
change
um so you see all of this chaos and that
provides uh
it creates flexibility within a rigid
system that allows the system to
transition into something new and higher
so you think that this is a function of
the universe the universe has a tendency
towards complexity and that we are one
of the driving forces of this yes so
we're a biological driving force of a
greater law of the universe
yeah
and but what do you think the universe
wants like what's the ultimate goal of
this so um
you know when you talk about what the
universe wants we're already getting
into like a little language trap because
yeah are we saying that the universe is
conscious that it has a conscious intent
i don't think so well let me ask it in a
different way where do you think this is
going
well no it so it's it's good to kind of
break that down and be like
does the universe have a conscious
intent so i don't think it does but i
think it has
a sort of design and when i say design
it's something that's not mystical i'm
saying that the laws of physics
are such that
complexity increases
and
the universe does have something like a
goal so it may not have a conscious
intent but life emerges inevitably and
that the laws of physics plays something
uh
you know analogous to uh
dna in an organism so the laws of and
constants of physics are sort of cosmic
dna
that ensures that this evolutionary
program
plays out
so
uh
maybe the universe is moving towards
something like a cosmic attractor
and an attractor is
a term that physicists use to describe
a state of order
so for example when you take the stopper
out of your bathtub you will get the
formation of a whirlpool so you get this
spontaneous order gravity is attracting
the water down the pipe and yep so so
you have these attractors which are
basically kind of this goal state of
system in living systems attractors
are basically states of stability that
that the system that the living system
is trying to maintain against this
second law of thermodynamics
and uh
so
um it seems like cosmic evolution is a
process of
generating increasingly
complex attractors so when i say that
there are these evolutionary transitions
which are versions of phase transitions
that i just explained
so
if you look at the story of the universe
it's a story of nature's simplest parts
coming together to form larger
functional holes so atoms come together
to make molecules which come together to
make cells which come together to make
multicellular organisms which come
together to form societies and now we
have something like the emergence of a
global brain which is uh the network of
humans connected by the internet as well
as ais and so when humans uh leave the
planet like
people out there like elon musk with
spacex are trying to get humans off the
planet i'm saying that that's part of
this natural evolutionary process it
wasn't just like a decision someone made
or you know something that we decided to
do
because we're clever or something it's
actually baked into this process
and uh that's because if life is going
to continue to persist it has to get off
the planet before its
star dies
so it's sort of it creates like a game
clock that forces life to spread
what is the end state
maybe something like this cosmic
attractor where
some very legitimate scientists have
speculated people like paul davies
ray kurzweil you know technology guy may
seem you know futurists may seem a
little bit more out there but
there's this idea that you know the
universe is evolving uh and waking up
and that
there could be this
integrated state where something like a
cosmic mind emerges from this process
is uh is it an egocentric way of looking
at consciousness to think that the
universe is waking up i mean we are this
tiny speck that's riding on one planet
that is but a molecule in the
vast infinity of the universe yeah for
us to say oh one day the universe will
catch up with us yeah be conscious like
us
isn't that kind of goofy like but isn't
it like if you think about it isn't it
kind of an egocentric
biological function the idea that
consciousness the way we term it
thinking about all our problems and the
way we fit in with the universe and
coming up with solutions for
unique situations that we have to deal
with we think that's so amazing but the
universe is literally they have stellar
nurseries out there they're creating
stars
we have hypernovas stars are exploding
that create carbon which is
literally the the building blocks for
all carbon-based life that's all that
stuff is happening we're like yeah one
day they're going to catch up it's going
to be conscious
why is consciousness even important well
first of all you need stars and planets
to have consciousness right that's part
of the process too the first ordered
structures that were created by this
cosmic evolutionary process which
includes life
are
those
those ordered structures and uh so
um
well one point you made was that you
know
we're on this small planet uh what the
book argues and what a lot of origin of
life researchers are arguing is that
life isn't improbable it's probably not
only here
that where you have the right conditions
life emerges inevitably so if you have
the right ingredients it'll cook
something up
uh and that will be life so
there uh are estimated to be something
like you know
billions to maybe trillions of
earth-like planets out there that life
may have emerged on and maybe
intelligent life to assume that we are
the only
intelligence out there is to say that
what happened on this
planet is extremely almost infinitely
improbable
and i don't think that's the case people
like richard dawkins have argued that
life emerging on other planets will
evolve according to darwinian mechanisms
and these new
processes of self-organization
that we're describing and
so
if the
universe is waking up through life and
so when i say that i want to be very
clear i'm not talking about pan psychism
when i'm saying the universe is awake
i'm talking about just you know
conscious agents like us are awake and
the universe used to be all inanimate
matter prior to life so in a very
literal sense the matter in the universe
is waking up so if there is this process
and we find ourselves on this planet at
this point
it's of course going to look you know
like there's not much other life out
there and that consciousness doesn't
have this cosmic significance but that's
just how it looks
right now at this stage and we're
already starting to see
how technology can bring life off the
planet i mean
you know
a couple hundred years ago people
thought it was impossible to fly
actually i learned this from a friend
there was a new york times article that
came out something like 10 months before
the wright brothers created the plane
that said it would take like 10 million
years some ridiculously long amount of
time for humans to invent like you know
aircraft um so
we can already see
that this process um
basically has no limits
uh
and um
so
the the other thing you said was that
you know is it kind of like
anthropocentric uh to like you know
people think we're projecting human
qualities on the universe when you say
maybe like the universe is waking up but
i think that's a mistake
to to to talk about humans as if we're
not part of the universe we're part of
that physical system
so i don't think it's right to be like
oh consciousness is something that only
you know applies to humans and it's this
like quirky thing
we are part of the cosmos and you can't
strip away consciousness from the
description of the universe without
taking away
one of its most interesting aspects